hello everybody I'm Nick Gillespie with
reason I am joined by Zach weismiller my
colleague at reason and today we are uh
talking about The Tyree Nichols beating
death killing by uh at the hands of the
Memphis Police and we're joined by
Walter Katz uh Walter Katz is a uh he's
at Arnold Ventures which is a non-profit
or an advocacy group that does a lot of
work particularly on things like
criminal justice it was a 17-year public
defender in Southern California has
worked uh with the Chicago
administration of Rahm Emanuel to help
clean up their police department and
Public Safety and a bunch of other
things like that he's a uh an incredible
voice on police reform Walter thank you
so much for joining us today thank you
so much for having me Nick I really
appreciate it you too Zach yep thanks so
um let's let's start with talking about
uh you know what what we're going to do
is
um go through the Tyree Nichols uh
beating or incident
um we've got video I want to warn
everybody and I'll try to remember to do
this throughout we're going to be
showing not just the Nickels case but
other cases that are pretty rough going
uh so if you know people should be
forewarned about that
um but we're going to talk about this
particular instance and then talk about
what it says about policing in general
what it says about policing since George
Floyd uh and you know and going back to
Rodney King or B or even before that and
then larger questions about the the
reality and possibility for police
reform progress race in America and
things like that but um Zach why don't
we start first by uh you know beginning
let's show a clip of the incident in
Memphis that has launched this latest
you know forced conversation about
police violence yeah so this first clip
will be the when uh Tyree Nichols was
first pulled over at a intersection
um there there's going to be a couple
Clips here so that first we're going to
see him being pulled over we can discuss
what happened there and then we'll move
on to the actual uh beating that
occurred uh as he you know ran to uh uh
cul-de-sac so here is the uh here's
Terry being pulled over
the [__] out
of here
damn I need to do anything
hey I didn't turn your ass crap all
right all right all right all right
all right I'm on the ground
um
foreign
I guess uh you know as a first question
uh Walter some people argue that
representing or showing Clips like this
are themselves a form of violence or or
damaging to uh you know kind of public
discourse uh how do you feel about that
well things can be traumatic uh and do
some degree of harm but on balance or a
really important role of shunning light
on our government right this is State
action right and if we are interested in
understanding what our uh the limits as
well as what is the state capable of we
have to be able to see things like that
we have to be able to see things like
what happens to most vulnerable people
in our population and historical factors
is that black people are amongst the
most vulnerable people in American
society yeah and another thing I would
add is that you know I understand what
people are saying I mean I've been
looking at uh video footage and security
camera footage and not later body worn
camera footage of Police use of force
and police brutality uh going back now
you know two decades and I know the toll
that it takes and these things are hard
to watch
yeah
um it is uh important I mean I think a
lot of you know it this is too neat a uh
kind of division but I think a lot about
you know before and after Rodney King
and they transformative nature of the
video of police doing the things that
you kind of heard about but had no way
of understanding so you know the visual
impact of this stuff is rough it as it
is is really important talk uh you know
from from the point of view of somebody
who has uh you know prosecuted police
but and also worked with police
departments and other forms of law
enforcement in order to kind of make
things better what are your first you
know what what is going on in that scene
that is most important for people to
understand
yeah so my background you know first
began as a public defender for for many
years and defended people who are being
charged with either resisting arrest or
assaulting the police officer and this
is before the era of body one cameras
and a lot of security cameras so as
often uh the word of the officer against
uh the word of my client and very often
uh the system ended up believing the
officer uh the Advent of video footage
has changed has changed the equation and
then it spent many years either as a
police auditor or An Inspector General
reviewing incidents to select this and I
would say that what you see exhibited
there in the first two uh minutes is
extraordinarily stupid policing uh lack
of discipline a lack of exhibiting any
effort at the escalation or what often
police officers will say is taking
control of the scene so what you're
seeing is immediately the officers start
escalating you know guns are drawn
yelling contradictory commands not
explaining what they're doing there you
know if you see
um a a well-trained unit which is doing
what they would consider a high risk
stop and let's assume for a second the
officers thought for some reason this is
a high risk stop even though they claim
is this for reckless driving so I have
to assume this is what they do all the
time their tactics are off the charts
horrible and and ineffective right I
mean the fact is that he gets away
there's like they're swarming him and he
manages to run away completely
ineffective right if you if you're doing
a traffic stop with a certain uh
objective in mind which is removing the
person from the car because of some sort
of additional risk it's what LAPD would
call a felony a felony stop there's very
particular practices and how you do
those effectively while still
maintaining control of the person you're
seeking to detain and how they did it
here from Young commands to escalating
commands to giving contradictory
commands to yank him in out of the car
like that you know and then not even
have the technical skill uh to keep them
from running away uh it's it's like
before we get to the horribly uh um
sadistic of policing later on right now
we're seeing is horribly stupid policing
yeah
um Zach do you want to go to the yeah
let's go let's go right into that next
clip so this will this is you saw in
that clip he ran away
um and again
it's understandable to me why he would
run in that situation
um I I've Had The Misfortune of you know
being ordered out of a car and and
handcuffed for kind of this case of
mistaken identity and the cops were
relatively civil in that case it was
still it was it's terrifying just to be
brought out of your car and handcuffed I
can't imagine being slammed to the
ground and yelled all these orders and
you're trying to comply and then there's
mace and tasers flying so I I think that
people are that I I've seen a line of
commentary out there that uh well you
know don't run from the police and this
won't happen but that's a I mean it's so
hard to put yourself in that situation
and we can also talk about the context
later of the reputation of this
particular unit and how that that could
have played a role psychologically but
in any case uh some other officers met
up with him as he fled to a nearby
neighborhood that apparently
um you know was was near where his
mother's house may have been but um
these I have spliced together two
different a few different angles here
one is from a
um a Lamppost so it's a high angle shot
and then you see some of the same uh off
the officers body cams and I may
interject a couple times just to narrate
to help people follow what's going on
here
so here's the high angle shot you can
see them on the ground
um they're again trying to
subdue him that you've seen officers
after they've they've caught up to him
after he ran yes they caught up with him
an officer has a baton out and now he's
beating him with a baton
so yeah told him
yeah go ahead Walter so you're seeing
you've seen his baton strikes they seem
to be pretty on focused
again a lot of poor tactics lack of
control so what uh sadly Mr Nichols ran
into smack dab as compliance culture
he wasn't complying so you know they
take that as an affront because from
what I can say and they kept on upping
the Andy yeah well and we'll see that's
that same scene there from a different
angle now
um and with some sound
[Applause]
hey
what's up what's up
get ready
mom
give me a hand give me okay all right
all right
okay basically now
you're saying he's complying that
essentially at this point when he says
oh right his hands are going behind his
back now he he is complying so I think
that a lot of officers you know let's
assume everything that just happened
before with a really poor tactics and an
unnecessary escalation and inflammatory
language that none of that has happened
and you have somebody who is ostensibly
uh has presented some resistance he's
saying all right now and they have
control of his hands
that's right
oh [__]
give me a [__] hands
I think this is really important with
the body One camera footages show often
you're saying why do officers use force
and they use Force because they have a
reasonable belief in the threat to
themselves or a threat to others or
they're trying to seek compliance
depending what the threat is that's
presented depends about how much force
should be used now this officer whose
body worn camera we just showed
obviously did not think it was that
urgent because he had completely stepped
back to the who that vehicle he was
taking a break cut and then what he was
thinking and then he decides to
re-engage does he re-engage because
there's some sort of an ongoing threat
that he now has to control or is it
re-engaging because he now he wants to
go in and get some licks so again you're
showing a complete breakdown uh in what
policing should be
look at this give us your hands
give us your hands same location
I mean you can hear them slurring
semi-conscious uh the the question I I
have out of that clip is you know when
to most people including myself that
looks like a beating of a at some point
helpless and relatively defenseless guy
to the point of unconsciousness and as
you mentioned they're they they keep
yelling do this with your hands let me
see your hands even though that it seems
like they had him some under control
these guys know that they're wearing
body cameras why would they do this
knowing that it's all on camera
well in the end and then subsequently
they filed a false police report with a
narrative uh
I'm going to speculate here for a second
okay and the speculation is that when
you have officers who in engage in
um excessive force and violations of the
Fourth Amendment on a regular basis
they are essentially wrong to dice every
single time that it is not going to go
too far to get too much attention so I
don't know for example how did internal
controls work within the Memphis Police
Department but many agencies when there
is a use of force there's an escalating
level of Investigation if an officer
uses what they call personal weapons
which is hands and and fists uh perhaps
a pepper spray
that's only going to be a low level of
Investigation which in many agencies uh
perhaps their Sergeant is going to look
at that report and sign off on it and
he's not or she's not going to go that
far past this reading their own
narrative because when the injuries
become more serious some agencies for
example will require Internal Affairs to
respond to any use of a taser or any use
of head strikes with a baton to the head
but generally it's it's a it's
remarkable how much force an officer can
use which doesn't kill somebody and
which doesn't cause serious injuries to
trigger an internal affairs arrest and
these types of officers
except for the really dumb ones I'm not
sure which category these guys fall into
those types of sadistic officers they
know where the boundaries are they know
that they can inflect a lot of pain if
they want to without triggering it into
an escalating investigation here they
miscalculated go ahead nick uh I was
going to say I've read accounts that the
the officers that were involved in this
particular incidence have between three
and six years experience so you know
um you know that they're not green right
they're not rookies this isn't their
first month or even first year on the
job but is that considered are they
seasoned officers or are they for this
type of work
um because they're also and I guess we
can talk a little bit about that you
know the fact that they were part of a
of a special unit within the police uh
scorpion which is a ridiculous acronym
for you know you know basically cops
being allowed to uh kind of have more
free reign on stuff but like is is there
is it the length of their service here
in issue or is it mostly the lack of
training uh and restraint
uh a range of issues or a hand here yeah
you identified uh two of them uh
experience lack of training supervision
what systems have been put in place for
accountability uh all these all fit
together create a culture within an
agency which will signal to officers of
how much that they can uh could get away
with and also
um the lack of well whether or not
there's professionalism in terms of how
um uh tactics are are used what they
would call defensive tactics in training
um either
there's two possibilities here either
these officers are not well trained on
defensive tactics or they didn't use any
of those lessons that they learned and
there was a lack of supervision to make
sure that they were uh using tactics
that they were trained on to that
experience question when when I was uh
uh the independent Police auto during
the city of San Jose and this was during
uh the year 2016. when we looked for
example at uh use of force data and
complaint data uh particularly from
2015. and and mapped that against
experience level of officers we did see
clusters of use of force complaints uh
really uh clustered amongst the least
experienced officers like one to five
years of experience
and that's one of the challenges of how
you can create systems which make
excessive force more likely so for
example often even though Memphis for
example uh if I recall the state of
Tennessee does not allow officers to
collectively bargain uh but many
agencies who are under a collective
bargaining uh their Union contracts give
uh preferences by seniority for shift
and location so often you have the least
experienced officers who are working
together often into quote unquote least
desirable precincts or districts and
during a busy what they call the busiest
times night time and if you also have
sergeants contracts which have the same
system you'll have them supervised by
the least experienced sergeants so
there's a way that these systems are
feeding into each other to allow for the
conditions that can happen like here can
I ask before uh Zach Johnson uh again
you know you you kind of suggested or or
it seemed implicit in your conversation
that cops know what they can get a get
away with and they're going to go right
up to that line is it in your experience
and you've you've worked with police all
over the country is there a is there a
sense that they are in a war or that
they are occupy you know this is
something I'm thinking back to the uh
the Dennis Hopper movie with Sean Penn
and uh Robert Duvall colors you know the
idea that the LAPD you know it often
gets brooded about that they see
themselves as an occupying Army in in a
in a city that they're like you know
holding down is that your sense of
things or is it that you know most cops
don't see themselves as that way they
see themselves more as as actual
peacekeepers or or custodians of social
stability
well I think even the latter can can buy
into trouble but I I think that in my
experience of having looked at hundreds
of use of force incidents and those
which border which are excessive force
aboard an excessive force there is a a
strata of officers who are
consciously going up to the Limit and
sometimes Beyond
and that this is kind of a not all
officer's kind of statement most
officers I do think are are doing their
jobs and are actually doing their jobs
well
except insofar as it comes to
controlling what their fellow officers
are doing so sometimes you'll find units
especially just kind of specialized
units which are a little walled off from
everyone else where they can get away
with things because nobody else is
watching them and and that's why I think
the state of the art and policies our
duties to intervene in a duty to report
when you see misconduct and also a duty
to render Aid uh to somebody who's been
injured so there's a series here across
the board and all three yeah this uh the
wall of silence is a is a big issue here
though yeah and it plays out in an
interesting way and I've seen this
happen in numer numerous use of force
reports I've read over the years where
the the questionable conduct is often
not seen
by their colleagues you know they'll be
interviewed by Internal Affairs and you
know did you see officers such and such
uh would BC officers such and such do
right and that officer you know is
accused of unnecessarily punching the
guy in the head and the witness officer
will say I don't know I was focused on
his feet I didn't know what's happening
up above and for me there was always a
head scratcher uh since this is a
profession which they're trained and
expected to be observant of what's going
on around them to have situational
awareness but for too often that
situational awareness breaks down when
it comes to noticing what their
colleagues are doing
speaking of the the wall of Silence the
the this last clip I want to play from
the incident is the aftermath so it's
when Tyree Nichols is you know they kind
of pushed him up against the car he's
just slouching over there and they're
all talking through what they think just
happened or what maybe they want to say
just happened a lot of it to me did not
sound like what I saw happen on the tape
but I would like to get your reaction to
the way that the officers are talking
about the incident right after it
happens is they're waiting for the
ambulance
yes
I'll just note right there that there
was one of one of the officers there
saying remember your your camera is on
uh
bro I hit them on so many pieces
[Music]
bro you bro
we're taking his camera
hitting him with Haymakers
wow I almost hit me
he literally had his hand on my gun like
that [__] so we tried to I'm
talking about yes
yes he didn't stop we still instead of
trying to get himself
that might drove around swear like
you're gonna hit my car so then I'm like
God damn man what are we doing he pulled
up to the red like stop at the rear like
put his turn signal on so we can jump
out the car
she went from there
I know first of all is that appropriate
for them to be talking about this in
that way amongst themselves I mean I
would think that would compromise you
know if you're an independent
investigator the ability to kind of get
a story out of everyone once again it
really seems they're kind of you know
workshopping a narrative to tell about
what just happened yeah so I I think the
two clips are are important for how they
showed really two different phenomenon
going on uh the first was
um that immediate aftermath when
probably the cameras should not have
been on from their perspective
uh and you heard incredibly
unprofessional language and attitudes
being exhibited you know these guys were
just in the fight I mean these are all
big guys too right and uh Mr Nichols was
not a big guy and so just goes again to
show how incompetent their tactics were
that if they actually were trying to
deal with a combative person who he was
not uh that how prototactics were but
everything they were talking about you
know Haymakers and this and that show
this uh you know just admissions of
violence uh the second clip though is
that is was for the camera right and you
heard basically the one officer kind of
walking through the narrative where
everyone else could hear it and so my
guess would be if there was a subsequent
administrative's interview you would
hear pretty much everyone reflecting
that now I've not looked at for example
The Narrative from the police report
that was filed that night but my
suspicion is that if you listen to what
you just heard that one officer
explained there you're going to see a
pretty close narrative that was written
down in terms of how often that happens
that happens all the time all the time
uh where officers are discussing what
occurred it is treated as something
benign which it could be right but it
also serves a purpose for creating this
common understanding so everyone's
coming off the same song book so it's
not really benign now after an officer
involved shooting orders going to be a
more significant investigation usually
the first commander on the scene or the
first supervisor on the scene their
obligation is to separate everybody and
before the conversation takes place in
their in a good agency they're driven
them separately back to uh their station
uh driven by somebody else but here they
seemed like they had a lot of time to
chat with each other so I mean it's it's
the if it's the same as if You Came Upon
a criminal activity and there's four
people hanging out you separate them so
that they're not going to kind of get
their story all kind of consonant with
one another yeah and here's you're going
to see sometimes officers get the ire up
because if you draw an analogy saying If
This Were a crime he had four civilians
also a robbery the first thing you would
do is separate the civilians and and
officers will say well you know we're
not like that we're just trying to
independently recollect what occurred
and that's why this is one of these
cultural phenomenons that occur
in my experience very often
um in policing they don't actually even
see their own built-in biases and how
their culture is organized so when
people think there are these conscious
efforts to collude to make a false
statement would you just saw it seem
really benign and almost natural where
they don't even recognize that that is
what they're actually doing
there there's also mention in there
several of them keep implying that he
was on drugs he was high you know I
don't know if that was the case or not
that they also didn't know because I
don't think they did a toxicology report
at that moment uh but regardless that
the behavior that he was exhibiting in
that first clip when he's getting pulled
over he seems to be speaking pretty
lucidly to the police and saying hey
come on you guys are doing a lot right
now can you stop it I mean it doesn't
look like this is some guy freaking out
on on drugs on amphetamines or something
like that how common is
kind of injecting oh he was high on
drugs into the conversation I I think
that you know and uh
there's a there's a piece by Sue rarr in
the Atlantic that was published a couple
days ago and and she is the former
Sheriff of King County she ran the whole
um uh Academy system for the state of
Washington and in her essay in the
Atlantic um she she talks about
um that type of insular insularity and
of how
um enough how that plays out where
you're basically doing this reductive
justification of the thing that took
place but the most important thing is to
set off that person as the bad guy so
either he's involved in a violent crime
or he had a gun or you thought he had a
gun or he's on drugs what you're doing
is you're setting that person off as
being as being othered and you know you
will even see that How Deeply cultural
that is that when you will see
um a use of force report an officer
while shooting report a criminal
investigation they will always list the
person who upon whom force was used by
the police as as the assailant and the
officer as the victim
um and that's before the investigation
has even concluded it begins with that
framing officer is the victim the other
person's diasailing so you're just
seeing that culture playing out in how
they are talking about it as they're
starting to frame the incident as being
drug related can I um in the interest of
kind of moving the conversation along a
little bit
um you know the one of the my first
question is you know we're looking at
these clips Without Really any context
and you know the context hasn't been uh
given by the Memphis you know the the
city government or the police uh
Department all of these guys have been
fired the police chief very quickly said
you know like God these guys were acting
terribly they deserve to be fired and I
we won't run the clip in the interest of
time but she goes so far as to say you
know they really screwed up
um two quick questions one is is it fair
to kind of public discourse to look at
this stuff without any context is there
a way in which we might pull back and
suddenly see how all of this makes some
some sort of sense
um you know that we're not seeing now
and then secondly can we can we move
from the uh I guess answer the answer
that first first and then let's go to
the next level of responsibility here
yeah now keep that brief you can never
say never right and even the chief said
that we've the officers claim that the
reason for the Stop was reckless driving
uh We've not seen any evidence of that
so perhaps
there there was something but again
officers are supposed to continuously
reassess the situation and so we start
time at when they first approached the
vehicle you can already start accounting
for their conduct and to degree it was
appropriate or not almost regardless of
what the reason was for the stop right
um so let's go to that next level of
responsibility you know this and this is
something
um shortly we'll talk about you know uh
discussions of progress and policing or
at least understanding the the extent of
issues with policing
um but you know the the police chief was
like uh these guys you know I don't know
who they were but they were not acting
and you know they they were bad people
here what you know how do you how do you
move from you know it seems you know
unquestionable that these guys did not
know what they were doing or or rather
whatever they were doing it was bad and
it was wrong uh ineffective and deadly
awful but is is that are they to blame
or is it then the police department in
Memphis and the training and how do we
start to kind of unpack that or or
figure out what what we do next
well
a cities and a police department's
leadership do help set the tone and they
do help put systems in place which allow
for this kind of egregious
crime to occur
ultimately responsibility in terms of
individual choices that are made why
with all of uh the charged officers and
the other officers on the scene who
found who fail to render Aid or to
intervene or to report
but just because there's individual
responsibility
um like in the mob you know members of a
mob are all responsible for their own
individual Behavior but who instigated
the mob also holds culpability I'm not
saying there's instigation here and this
is much more complex what systems that
are created but you notice what just
happened here just a moment ago we're
having a conversation about how the
person upon whom force is used who's
been victimized by police brutality is
shifted into the other as a bad person
to be to be essentially othered or outed
and now you're seeing this exact same
thing occur with those officers well
they're not one of us they're not what
we stand for they are others they are
bad and that to an extent does absolve
that organizational responsibility look
these officers didn't create the
Scorpion unit they're not the ones who
sat around and came up with that
ridiculous acronym for a unit name and
they're not the ones who set them loose
on the streets of Memphis to enforce the
law with you know thousands of
aggressive traffic stops they're not the
ones who wasn't listening to the
community who are complaining about this
unit or took complaints seriously that
was all leadership you know and this is
a this is leadership which decided and
how to respond to a rising violent crime
not with for example increasing
Investments and focused on community
rounds intervention strategies but
focusing on aggressive policing
strategies which have been shown to not
only not be that effective when done
poorly but also to cause far more harm
as we see here can I ask a question
about the Scorpion unit
um there was this our former recent
staffer Radley Balco put this opinion
piece in the New York Times Tyree
Nichols his death proves yet again that
Elite Police units are a disaster he
talks about the Scorpion unit and their
their function their purpose uh four
groups of 10 officers each would
saturate crime hot spots in the city and
unmarked cars and make pretextual
traffic stops to investigate homicides
aggravated assaults assaults robberies
and carjackings and you've seen a lot of
media coverage along these lines that
the Scorpion unit is is really the is a
big part of the problem
um our special you know when you have a
city like Memphis that is experiencing a
violent crime an increase in violent
crime
is the very idea of an Elites or just
like special unit who's going to try to
focus on like the the the the really
concentrated crime hot spots is that
just a bad idea altogether or is it
something about this specific unit that
was going wrong
well when there are concentrations of
violent crime to the extent that they do
exist
how a police department in a city
designs its its response really matters
and so there is there is evidence that
um quote-unquote hot spots policing uh
can be effective but there are a lot of
caveats that go along with it and how it
is done is really important that it is
targeted is really important and it's
really interesting even how Radley
phrased toward a city uh Justified it
um you know this unit is going to focus
on homicides aggregated assaults and
carjackings you know these these type
one violent violent crimes
but the tactics that they used
were almost completely unrelated with
those types of offenses and it's kind of
that cast and White net approach will
stop lots of cars and stopping lots of
cars will use a pretext to try to do as
many searches as possible in the hopes
that we'll find evidence of guns I don't
see any indication that the unit for
example was designed to focus on people
who are potentially identified as being
involved in shootings and even that can
be questionable if it's not done
precisely I don't see any I don't see
anything that the unit was working
closely for example with the detectives
Bureau to be developing on the ground
evidence this is basically just a group
of jackals being let loose on the
streets
um so no the design is entirely poor and
it's not a surprise we can go back to as
long history of these so-called special
units with cool acronyms you know lapd's
crash units here we've got the Scorpion
unit Baltimore had the at the gun Trace
task force you you create these street
team units and give them unmarked cars
you let them feel cool because they can
wear hoodies at night time you don't put
a lot of controls on them you don't have
a feedback loop for the quality of
arrest that they make nobody's paying
attention to whether or not these
actually lead to actual charges nobody's
following how many complaints they're
picking up this is all in the name of
Public Safety and then there's a prized
when this has happened time and time and
time again yeah and I mean I I think uh
in a uh tweet thread that you uh put out
you talked about how actually in this
sort of response to increases in crime
or in Hot Spot policing what typically
works or what seems to be a better
approach is to actually make more of a
public display of policing of having you
know cops who are in uniform in marked
cars because that assures uh or or it
sends a signal that the police are
around and are on the lookout
um so is you you were talking about
sometimes this can be done well is that
something like comps that that we saw
come out of the New York City Transit
Police and ultimately the New York
police department in the 90s is that a
better way to go about policing
increases in crime or or localized
outbursts
data may tell you what is happening but
it's not telling you how to respond to
it right what did happen in New York
city where the ended up you know doing
stop and frisks on hundreds of thousands
of civilians mainly young black and and
and brown men
and yielding very uh you know either no
crime or evidence of criminality or
really low what must be considered low
low quality arrests of arresting people
for public showing of you know marijuana
whose possession was decriminalized I
think so you know so here at Arnold
Ventures you know um yeah rare
Foundation we do philanthropic giving
and it's really focused on uh you know
uh maximizing opportunity and minimizing
Injustice and the work we do on criminal
justice is trying to really develop
evidence to understand problems and
using evidence to identify Solutions and
then advocating for those types of
policy changes so we've spent some time
over the last year looking at traffic
stops for example so uh you know we've
we've supported work for example but uh
by the Public Public Policy Institute of
California ppic they do analysis of uh
what what of Ripa stock data the state
of California requires the collection of
of stock data they looked at data for
the 15 largest agencies in California in
uh in 2019 and they showed remarkably
low yield rates from traffic stop
searches in terms of how many guns are
found in many places you will find that
that you find yield rates you know in
the single digit percentages and but
those uh that Reliance on pre-text stops
are viewed as being pretty low-level
benign behavior until we ask people who
actually are subject to debtstop right
and for them it is not benign whatsoever
so that occurs thousands and thousands
of times again and so what I don't know
is how many stops is this unit making in
Memphis how many of those times would it
finding Contraband how frequently
working were they making arrests how
often were they making uh using Force
how often were they generating
complaints how many charges were being
filed and those are all those kind of
data points which are more does how
effective and legitimate is the policing
so first front end of data where is
crime occurring the second set of data
is how is the police response working
can I ask uh we've got you for about 15
more minutes
um so you know what what would be a
better response than to uh situations in
cities or neighborhoods where crime is
spiking
um you know what what is a better
response than creating a scorpion unit
that goes you know goes around prowling
and uh you know and then you know jumps
on you know a kind of random individuals
and can I can I put that question within
a little bit of context here this is
from the Arnold Ventures website and uh
the subhead here says that uh the
National Conference of State
legislatures documented more than 700
police reform bills in 2020 so that's
you know since the killing of George
Floyd there's been a big push for to to
uh reform push have
out of you know the those hundreds of
reforms you know is there anything
that's been particularly promising and
and then once you address that while we
still have you I'd like to go through a
few of the proposals that or or studies
that Arnold Ventures has has funded on
on specific reforms and gets you to uh
explain this but sure I think there are
some particular policies that we're
interested in and so our argument is
that very often when a horrible incident
occurs there's an effort to fix that one
particular problem so after George Floyd
there was this big push to uh stop choke
holds I'm assuming that now after uh uh
what happened in Memphis there's gonna
be a a push in terms of perhaps pretext
traffic stops but we're saying that
often it's the regulation of policing
where the state can play a much more
significant role in many ways policing
is a high risk profession or occupation
with very little regulation and those
are the exact Industries where there
probably should be more regulation which
carry great risk so for example you know
Studies have shown that when officers
get fired for misconduct in one agency
and they show up at a different agency
and get a new job but they're more
likely to commit misconduct so having
robust State Licensing processes which
include decertification for committing
misconduct so to control the wandering
officer problem would have a lot of
value uh how is use of force
investigated after a significant use of
force incident we're very interested in
in tightening up the rules there and
thirdly how are jurisdictions collecting
the data so some of those data points I
talked about a moment ago are
requirements for a collection and public
transparency so that both community
members Advocates and other policy
makers have a much clearer window into
the functions of their Police Department
could we talk a little bit more about
decertification because that that you
know one of the these problems that
seems to keep uh on being Unearthed when
these incidents occur is that often the
police involved have had prior problems
or prior complaints against them that
was the case against a couple of the
officers in involved in this incident
this is a screenshot of the national
decertification index which I guess
agencies can use to cross-reference when
they're hiring officers if there's been
a decertification of them in other
uh in previous jobs what are I I assume
that's something that for instance
police Unions would fight against pretty
hard uh I mean is is that the case has
has that been one of the major points of
resistance or are there are there other
major uh barriers to get past in order
to make decertification a lot easier
because in some sense it's like you
should it seems like it should be a lot
easier to clear out the problematic cops
who who are abusing people yeah I think
uh if you had a police Union guest here
he would be talking about the importance
of due process for for officers and I
think that as there has been a push for
more robust decertification often though
critique is uh from the law enforcement
Union side is that this takes away
rights from officers and I I strongly
disagree with that uh most
desertification systems still rely upon
the internal affairs or disciplinary
system of the agency to determine
whether or not somebody uh is out of
policy or not and whether or not it
rises to Serious misconduct that we can
have a separate conversation about
whether or not those would be
independent investigations which I tend
to lean towards now
what is this these certifiable conduct
is the first important question what
Falls was in that route I think
excessive force sustained excessive
force is pretty clear we should fall
within that committing a crime being
convicted of a crime should fall within
that pretty Clearly Now what are the
systems then in place for appealing
decertification is it shared across
Interstate lines is a law enforcement
agency required to check the
desertification index before hiring
those are all those types of rules which
should be included and invite folks to
look at one of our other partners NYU
Law school's policing project because
they've created model legislation on a
range of different policing issues
including what should be in a
desertification bill
and we're pretty excited that once we
set out of really focusing on more
robust decertification rules that we
began this effort uh they were still uh
of five states that did not have any
form of desertification and uh since we
began our effort and working with other
advocacy Partners around the country uh
California has come back online with
desertification state of New Jersey just
finally passed the bill last year uh
what we still want to see complete
compliance and that means that Hawaii
and Rhode Island uh need to get on board
and then there's a number of states
which have not looked back at
decertification in years and there are
there rules and policies are really out
of place we think it's a really really
important tool though so that officers
can't harm people and go off again and
do it elsewhere
just one follow-up Nick and then I'll
let you get in um one thing that you
always hear from uh police officers is
that whenever you talk about something
like decertification or something like
getting rid of qualified immunity which
present prevents them from getting sued
in civil court for violations that this
is and also just the general rhetoric
that happens around a lot of these uh
incidents that it's demoralizing and
it's going to cause it's gonna it's
harder it becomes harder to recruit
officers and there's there's more
attrition I mean there's there's some
evidence of an exodus in some cities
this is a article by Layton Woodhouse
where he cites a 2021 survey finding
police departments Nationwide saw
resignations Jump by 18 retirements by
45 then goes into some of the particular
cities that have been racked by protests
how do you implement these kind of
reforms these police accountability
reforms without making it so nobody
wants to be a police officer anymore
well first of all I think we should look
at some of these claims with a pretty
extreme eye of skepticism you know just
like often we don't have a really clear
idea of what causes for example crime to
go up or down a lot of claims were made
about the increase about the decreases
in officers uh in agencies in reality
the it is not that far outside the norm
second is is that anyone has paid
attention to that your aerial tables
would have known since the 1990s that
we're about to enter enter an era of a
lot of resignations and retirements
excuse me and why is that because during
the Clinton Administration they made a
significant effort at police officer
hiring so there's a hiring surge in the
early to mid 1990s and an officer
reaches a hundred percent pension
retirement gen generally most many
jurisdictions after 30 years of service
28 years of service you essentially can
retire with 100 salary as your pension
so we knew that the retirement wave was
going to come right about now now are we
seeing more are we seeing more a few
more resignations yes but the problem is
we don't exactly know why the survey
data and why offices are leaving is not
very clear there's been no real
crosstabulation to understand whether
agencies in cities that did not have
protest also have have issues we do know
uh from a study done by ABC News
Affiliates that very very few agencies
even uh had their budgets cut so it's
really hard to say exactly what is
driving officers uh uh to leave has the
work been tougher more scrutiny yes but
I think the goal should be to increase
professionalization of uh policing so
that what we saw in Memphis never
happens again
can we uh we've got you for a couple
more minutes
um but uh you know if if you take a
longer picture at the kind of history of
policing going back to you know the
early 70s or something like about 50
years ago I know when you look at
accounts of something like the NYPD you
know the amount of criminality that was
you know openly discussed by you know
police officers at the time and police
Commissioners as well as the violence
towards everybody that they encountered
the number of times that they had
violent interactions with uh you know
with citizens things are way down from
that period
um you know can you know and over the
past 10 years since the Michael Brown uh
uh deaths in Ferguson there has been
about 1100 murders by police so you're
not murderers uh killing police killings
a year that stayed relatively stable are
we are we actually in a period where
where policing is getting better but it
is that the misdeeds are more visible
because of not only body cameras but
also because of cell phones and and more
scrutiny being put on this I mean I I'm
not trying to say like okay we don't we
don't have to worry about anything but
actually we are in some way focusing on
the you know the last mile here as
opposed to entering a new era of you
know what might have been called
Giuliani uh time you know in in the 90s
in New York just to put some uh
statistical meet on that this is a
article from Billy Binion at reason who
was looking at a claim that uh last year
that uh police killing 1183 people in 22
was a record high and he went back and
looked at data that was compiled by uh
Peter Moscow said uh John Jay and found
that when you're you compare it to the
70s across the 18 major cities surveyed
there's been a 69 percent drop in fatal
police shootings New York City has been
quite dramatic as Nick mentioned so how
yeah I'm just putting that data out
there to kind of prime prime you for
that question yeah that's and that's
helpful to see and yeah if you go back
New York City's historical data and New
York was one of the few cities which
kept good data on officer-involved
shootings there has been a significant
Improvement I think for a number of of
different reasons uh but the reality is
until very recently such data was not
even being collected so it's a little
tough to say well it's at a record
number and then the count of that by
saying well no once we really scrape the
data together is actually much worse but
let's keep in mind that so far in the
first month of 2023 there have been some
high profile police involved uh killings
vote now Memphis and before that in Los
Angeles with the death of Keenan
Anderson school teacher from Washington
DC was clearly having some sort of a
mental health episode and died after
multiple applications of a taser I'm not
sure yet what the coroner is going to
say was the cause of death
the death of Mr Nichols neither of those
involved a gun right so if Nick if you'd
ask me this question let's say on
January 5th I would say yeah I think
some progress is being made But Here we
are now after what happened in Memphis
and you saw what actually took place I'm
not really comfortable with saying well
on balance things are better if
unbalanced things were truly better
would these officers had the felt the
freedom that they had
to viciously beat an innocent person the
way that they get so yeah maybe things
are better but they're clearly not good
enough and most importantly the racial
disparities have not disappeared we see
racial disparities in traffic stops and
who was searched on who forced and whom
forces used and who was killed I can
hear the response right now well that's
because black people are more
responsible for violent crime was Mr
Nichols carrying a gun was he a suspect
of a violent crime was it just some
other person who is exercising his
liberty interest of the freedom to
travel who was infringed upon by police
officers and that's what I think is what
happened uh very quickly so that you can
leave you know what what are the two or
three things that would most move the
public discussion forward in a way you
know where it's it's not about political
tribalism it's not about scoring points
it's about actually making Society safer
for everybody involved
I I think first and foremost I I would
like to have the concept of professional
policing put forward front and center so
there's a conversation about what do we
want out of our policing Force do we
want it to be a vocation an occupation
or do we want it to be an actual
profession and what are the requirements
that come with that and I think that the
bar should be set really high now we
have to accept the fact that this is a
country which has a lot of violent crime
we have to accept the fact that there is
a lot of guns out there it's not to say
that being a police officer is an easy
job but they come with a high degree of
responsibility and I would say that we
have to put a lot of focus on Mayors and
police Chiefs who've created the
conditions that allowed for that type of
unit to even exist the weight is allowed
to exist and have civil control of the
on the officers
thank you Walter Katz of Arnold Ventures
for talking to reason we're going to
continue the conversation uh thank you
again thank you so for giving me so much
air time uh so we could have an in-depth
conversation I really appreciate it all
right we'll do it again okay thank you
uh so Zach we uh I mean in a way I'm
like oh an in-depth conversation we
barely have scratched the surface of
Walter Katz's uh depth of knowledge but
also some of the things that we were
discussing in preparation for this what
is what's coming to your mind right now
in terms of a topic
um you know that we uh you know that we
didn't get to that you absolutely want
to yeah well there there was this this
was from uh Arnold Ventures
they looked at uh this project out of
Durham and uh Durham North Carolina
police department has this thing called
the heart program and it's this idea
that we've heard a little bit about uh
since police reform entered the
conversation in a big way after the
death of George Floyd of
um maybe you know unbundling the police
or making it so the police are not
necessarily the First Responders to to
everything and so this shows that you
know they've created a community
response teams for something like a
welfare check or a mental health crisis
they have crisis call counselors from
the crisis called uh where they oh and
then they have like clinicians paired
with police and uh that's an intriguing
idea to me I think that this is a it's a
pilot program it would have been nice to
hear Walter talk a little bit about it
but I don't think we have too much data
from that but experiments like that are
interesting to me he talked a lot about
um you know traffic stops and how a lot
of incidents occur from that where and
the yields from you know tasking a team
like scorpion to go out and do as many
traffic stops as possible to try to you
know dig something up
doesn't seem to pay off
um and so that's one thing I've always
been interested in in the police reform
conversation is could is it possible to
have the police do less and be more
focused on the things we want them to
focus you know I I think as a broad
principle it may be uh this is a shift
that we need to be making in the 21st
century away from creating ex you know
of from kind of uh expecting existing
public sector workers that I'm thinking
of teachers and I'm thinking of cops and
whatnot like where you start to say well
teachers you know they're not just
supposed to teach they're also supposed
to be kind of therapists and
nutritionists and they're you know
they're going to be social workers and
cops are going to be social workers and
whatnot and that instead of loading up
existing professions with more
responsibilities that really kind of
cloud and get you know sideways is with
the primary function of police or of
teaching or whatever unbundling these
things into different categories because
it I mean it seems self-evident that you
know you don't you you know if you call
the police because somebody somebody is
howling at the moon and they might be
you know they might be brandishing a gun
or a knife like you want some kind of
law enforcement there but they're not
going to be the the right person to deal
with that how you do that effectively
and without breaking the bank
um you know these are all I I think
legitimate questions I think for me one
of the other
um you know questions that we didn't
fully get to Air and then maybe we can
run through some questions yeah uh uh
you know and comments as they've come up
but is the question of you know and this
was particularly after Michael Brown and
Ferguson which is really you know the
the moment a decade basically a decade
ago uh when you know the conversation
about police uh violence race but
especially police violence became front
and center was the idea that body
cameras were going to be a real game
changer
um you know and this was drawing off of
the energy from uh Rodney King you know
the idea that a citizen you know
videographer a guy was testing out a
video recorder
caught this unbelievable beating you
know that ushered in a new era of kind
of surveillance of you know people from
below uh looking at people in charge
phones did that you know in a way cell
phones and everybody becomes a kind of
recorder a citizen recorder a citizen
journalist we've written a lot about uh
and done a lot of videos about whether
or not it's legal for citizens to tape
the police you know while they're doing
their stuff and it is always and
everywhere uh the police don't like that
but now this next step of you know that
body cams were going to change things
and it's not you know it's not clear
that they have systematically they
definitely body cam footage in
particular instances has seen if not
Justice get done create the Groundswell
for reform in which down the road
Justice might become possible yeah and
it might be worth playing this excerpt
that we have from uh former recent DAV
uh stepher Paul Dietrich did a lot of
documentaries about of policing body
cameras he did something on uh he did
several videos on on the Kelly Thomas
case uh which which you'll see here in a
moment I'm going to ask Adam our
backstage producer to play them here
[Music]
thank you
Kelly Thomas died a few days after that
beating today in court we're hearing
accusations of how Thomas was pummeled
and left lying in a pool of his own
blood and on the night of July 5th 2011
he posed no threat at all to the police
or to anyone else the suspect was
uncontrollable he couldn't handcuff them
they couldn't control him and officers
trained basically to control secure and
that train to tie and this was not even
a tie prosecutors said that the last
words out of his mouth were God help me
Daddy they're trying to kill me daddy
during opening statements from the D.A
you know choked me up again with Kelly
calling out for me without that City
video
Kelly would just be like everybody else
who was murdered by the police and there
would never have been charges
now so I mean there's a lot there a lot
of similarities actually to this case
there's the issue of the officers
seeming to not know how to restrain
someone in a non-lethal way there's the
issue of of the cameras and what role
they played I mean his father there
makes the case now we're getting a
little more acclimated to police
officers in these incidents actually
getting charged I mean even convicted
sometimes in the case of Derek shovin in
the Floyd case uh back then this was
nine years ago it wasn't common for
police officers to even go to trial
these these officers were ultimately
acquitted so then there was a long
period of officers getting caught on
tape enough public pressure forcing them
to trial but then getting acquitted now
it seems like for whatever reason juries
are more willing to hold officers
criminally responsible we'll see what
happens in The Tyree Nichols case but I
would say that's a case for body cameras
uh you know unfortunately
as this case shows us
maybe police officers have just gotten
acclimated to them and they just are
they or they don't think what they're
doing is is wrong or something but uh at
least I I do think there there are still
value in being able to see it and it it
can create some um you know momentum for
there to be Justice in the form of of a
trial
um and also we also you can't of course
measure the amount of times a police
officer did restrain himself because he
knew that right no absolutely the other
thing that uh you know uh that uh you
know Pro body cam reformers bring up
that I think is important is it can also
exonerate police and has been used uh to
that end so it's kind of a win all
around in in that sense yeah I I I
absolutely uh agree with that and it
does get down to this question of course
you know and this is implicit in the
Rodney King case where in the original
trial the defense successfully broke
down the video in a way that exonerated
the police they were acquitted by a jury
you know that later changed in a later
federal trial but
um it's never going to be one thing or
the other but it's better to have it
just to run through some of the
questions here before we sign off uh TF
asked question for panel does race play
a role in this if so why uh why is the
media and individuals saying it is
racist you know I think race does play a
role in this in in the way that Walter
Katz was talking about that there remain
uh real discrepancies in the way that
policing is done and the way that
certain populations particularly black
men of a certain age are over policed
and it's you know so in that sense I
think it plays a role both in the Kelly
Thomas case you know that we just talked
about here but also in this one the fact
that the officers who did the beating
were also black it's given and rise to
some you know uh articles and headlines
saying you know that blacks have
internalized white supremacy
et cetera et cetera I don't find that
particularly convincing but I think what
is helpful in this case and this goes
beyond race is that it will focus on
actual police activity
um because in the end you know police
could be stopping people at you know uh
for reckless driving and not killing
them as they did in this case
um another uh Kevin uh Clause
4p55p says stricter hiring including
psych tests better pay for good cops
more rigorous training fire cops that
make bad choices yeah that's a lot of
what Walter was talking about there uh
we didn't talk about psych tests so I'll
leave that one there but better hey more
rigorous training certainly or even I
don't know if rigor is even the right
way to think about it but he seems to be
saying a type of training that
um kind of a sort of de-escalation
training that either was not present in
this case or uh the the officers were
not following
um you know we don't know what sort of
training the Memphis Police Department
had but whatever it was it was certainly
not applied in this case and so and
there's that question too of you know
de-escalation tactics and from what I've
read uh you know police forces in Europe
actually tend to do this better because
they don't partly because they don't
face as much gun crime so the police
oftentimes either are not carrying guns
or they're slower to respond with guns
but a lot of de-escalation uh tactics
and Technology such as tasers end up
weirdly getting in the way of police
actually doing de-escalation because
they're like I have a non-lethal way of
ending this by tasing somebody tasering
somebody or or hitting them with a baton
which is supposed to be non-lethal and
it actually kind of gets in the way of
you know what that those pieces of
Technology are in the you know are in
the mix to begin with
um but I also think it's worth talking
for a second about these other two items
better pay for good cops and fire cops
that make bad choices I mean the
decertification conversation we had
earlier was about partially being able
to not only fire cops that make bad
choices but then to not have other
departments rehire them by having some
way to track like did this individual
get fired from another department for
some really terrible incident or that
you're going to keep playing kind of uh
you know uh musical chairs with these
people and this is where I see a
connection to the way that um we've seen
teachers in certain school districts
kind of you know there there's some bad
apple teachers there was famously in New
York City that would be put in the
rubber rooms because they couldn't even
be fired so they would just sit in a
room all day because the union wouldn't
let the district fire this teacher and
so there's I think that also relates to
higher pay for cops because if you can't
fire the bad cops you can't you don't
have the budget to pay the good cops
more money and so I think that's
partially what Walter's talking about
with a professionalization of policing
you you need to break that relationship
and that that bureaucracy uh and that
that relationship between the public
sector Union and the political class in
these cities that is upholding its power
I to me that's kind of a Bedrock
fundamental thing that until you do that
you're not really going to be able to
get to a real professionalization yeah
and I don't think any of that is going
to be easy whether we're talking about
teachers or cops for instance you know
uh obviously you can incentivize good
behavior and punish bad behavior but
what is a good cop you know is a good
cop somebody who makes a lot of arrests
is it a good cop who never gets brought
up on charges of you know making too
many arrests or being a little bit you
know uh handsy on certain types of
arrests it's complicated and it's going
to have to be adjudicated and you know
certain types of work are more given to
collective bargaining which doesn't mean
everybody gets paid exactly the same but
it
bureaucratizes the relationship between
employer and employee and and to your
point uh you know and to Walter Katz's
point about Mayors and police
Commissioners being held responsible for
changing the culture
um you know that's absolutely the case
Richard Larose on Facebook asks uh or
says hold sergeants lieutenants and
captains responsible for the conduct of
their officers the chain of command
knows who should not be cops long before
something bad happens until the chain of
command starts being prosecuted like
CEOs and officers of company nothing
will change law and order as necessary
for civilization to exist you know I
think creating that kind of
um you know real like accountability at
every level is you know fundamental and
you know one of the questions I guess uh
or or one I think this is no longer a
question there was an idea well in order
to keep the peace you have to kind of
turn a blind eye to crack the heads like
um you know in the Errol Morris
documentary The Thin Blue Line from the
late 80s which was about a um uh uh
police uh police officer being shot
during a a traffic stop and then
ultimately the wrong person being you
know put on death row about that but the
judge in that case famously choked up
while he was listening to the
prosecution talk about how the police
were The Thin Blue Line Between chaos
Etc like I think as a society we have
moved to a place where virtually
everybody recognizes the necessity and
the power of the police
um for good but also that we need we can
no longer start to just say well you
know what like invading armies occupying
armies policemen certain types of people
who put their self put the you know
public servants put themselves at risk
we have to let them blow off steam we
have to give them more latitude that
we're not in that place anymore and we
shouldn't be
um but this chain of uh of
responsibility that has to be you know
at the fractal level every cell of every
person who's involved in this needs to
be held responsible and know it and
enforce it throughout the system yeah
easier said than done yes and some of
that uh has some of that
happens through some competitive
pressure or some feeling that that we're
we're not stuck with just this one
Commander or this this one agency even
you know there's always different uh law
enforcement agencies kind of overlapping
within districts and also that idea we
were talking about earlier of trying to
unbundle or you know bring in uh other
experts besides police to deal with
every situation if there's other
agencies that begin to prove themselves
more competent in certain areas you can
shift away from the corrupt institutions
and put that sort of pressure on them to
reform so that that's another aspect I
think of trying to make it so that
it's not you're just not just pouring
more and more money into a an
institution that has these problems and
hoping that if you fund it enough it's
going to somehow change yeah that's I I
think that's a good libertarian point
and a good reason point to uh to focus
on you know giving more money to a
broken system you know just creates you
know more spending on a broken system it
doesn't fundamentally fix it and that's
true of Education it's true of policing
it's true of Defense uh and things like
that but uh by the same token I think
and uh you may disagree with me on this
I've written a lot about how
um when trust and confidence in
institutions whether they're private or
especially public government
institutions decline people lose you
know there it's impossible to be
accountable and I at the same time
people give those public institutions
more power because they're worried about
chaos and things like that and I think
there's a bit of horseshoe Theory going
on between Libertarians and Progressive
leftists in the all cops are bastards
Camp um if you actually believe that
police are inherently racist or
inherently sexist or inherently violent
and awful and incompetent and a Scourge
upon the land
um there is no hope for reform actually
and this is where I think you know from
a specifically libertarian perspective
what we need to be doing is narrowing
the scope and certainly the spending uh
you know of public action but we need to
be narrowing it and holding our public
actors whether we're talking about you
know the defense industry or you know on
the national level or uh you know
welfare at the state local and federal
level but things like education and
police we have to narrow the scope of
what we expect these people to do and
then hold them accountable
um because otherwise if it is just
simply all cops are bastards they're all
evil you know it's the you know kind of
the extreme right and the extreme left
in many ways kind of coming together on
that you know then uh we're screwed you
know and we're not gonna We're Not Gonna
See police budgets get cut I mean as you
know Walter was talking about and I
think reason to shown like you know
police police departments were not
defunded after George Floyd uh you know
any more than the FAA is going to be
defunded after causing you know a
massive traffic snafu over the holiday
they're going to get more money
um the real thing to do is to narrow
their their scope of authority and then
hold them accountable for results that
are actually in the public interest yeah
this commenter uh Chuck E cheese which
is appropriate for the gravity of this
conversation uh but treating treating
these officers as though they are a
representation of Greater policing is
like treating antifa as a their
representatives of free speech in
America that's echoing the point that
you're making about
you know it's kind of just waving away
that all police are yeah all cops are
bastards and uh it's an irredeemably
corrupt institution uh you know I think
the more productive
thing is to be focused on what should
the police be doing and yeah we as
Libertarians believe they should be
protecting people's lives and their
property and uh pretty much not not too
much beyond that really and I think that
it's the creep beyond that that caught
has caused a lot of the problems I mean
drugs are you know the drug war really
is the background to yeah so many of
these incidents um even in this Tyree
Nichols uh incident uh you know you we
talked about earlier how the police are
constantly saying oh he was he was high
he was high on something
um and and we don't know and that's you
know perhaps setting some sort of you
know pretext so that it's often you know
uh searching for drugs is just the
pre-test for getting involved with
something that never needed to be get
involved with uh in in the first place
and so yeah the I think that saying that
uh you know even even an anarchist is
going to say you know you're going to
need some sort of security force uh it
just needs to be focused on the things
that we all want which is Public Safety
and uh protection no I you know the drug
war is you know is uh I've I've talked
about it uh for decades now as a kind of
structuring uh reality in every aspect
of American life and and political life
as well as social and cultural life it
is there in education it is their
informed policy it is there in you know
in medical practice obviously in all
sorts of ways but when you hear police I
mean I get a shiver down my spine every
time you hear police say like he must
have been high on something or he seemed
to be high on something his people
peoples were dilated he had super
strength you know usually he not always
but this is an old script that goes back
you know a hundred years uh in fears of
cocaine Negroes uh that people you
Google cocaine Negroes in the New York
Times and you'll see you know early
iterations of this
um it's a it's a bad uh kind of motif in
American life and that is also changing
I think you know people are starting to
understand that the drug war is kind of
a get out of jail free card for all
kinds of dumb stupid oftentimes criminal
Behavior by government I want to point
out uh this uh one uh person here who
paid ten dollars
to ask a question uh TF he says do you
think or she they say do you think race
plays a role where were hiring standards
lowered by the city or station regarding
criminal history what is the service
history of the officers was everyone
involved drug tested you know um we've
we've kind of covered a lot of this
stuff one question about the hiring
standards
um you know I doubt that any Police
Department in the country is like you
know what we don't care if you are a
violent felon we're going to hire you
anyway but
um that question of vetting of police
officers and of what they've done in the
past and
um you know I think it's a you know it's
a fair question I mean police we expect
them we give them a lot of power we
expect them to do a lot they are
actually well compensated good one
should be paid more bad one should be
fired but these are uh you know the real
you know these are these are basic root
level questions that need to be answered
and I do think the question about race
needs to be discussed more forthrightly
people tend to not want to talk about it
or they go into I think platitudes of
just saying well of course you know
America is a white supremacist country
America is a racist country it's there
in the beginning it's there you know in
the colonies and it's now here I think
that simplifies things and it actually
clouds first off it's wrong I mean
America has many racially uh you know
kind of dictated or oriented sins that
we have not yet paid for fully but we've
also overcome a lot of that and the
promise of America and the reality of
America is not that it is here to uphold
white supremacy quite the opposite
um but we need to be able to talk about
the ways in which race still plays Aid
absolutely important role in certain
types of activities and deal with that
so that this doesn't become a Republican
or a Democratic talking point and
nothing you know you you rub a bunch of
sticks together and get some smoke but
you don't get anything that actually is
useful or it's going to change the
situation I think that with with regards
to race it's an important layer that uh
it needs to be addressed in a lot of
different situations but
incidents like this and the Kelly Thomas
incident we showed earlier are at least
sufficient to show that even if we got
rid of all the problems of racism that
that doesn't it's not going to solve the
problem um you know right Kelly Thomas
was a white mentally ill guy these were
five black officers doing this to a
black uh uh suspect who they pulled over
um that you know race can play effect
obviously can plays a factor in you know
how much interaction people have with
police officers but if you even if you
took that totally out of the equation
and you solved all that
they're still going to be unjust police
killings and I think it was important
what you were bringing up earlier with
Walter trying to put the numbers in
context historically and say
yes it's not acceptable for anyone to be
treated the way that Tyree Nichols was
treated it's also important to
acknowledge that things were really bad
30 40 years ago and there's been
significant improvements and now maybe
there's been a little bit of a flat line
there on the Improvement and now we're
trying to figure out really targeted
interventions to just push that down as
low as possible so that this virtually
never happens like that is you know
we're never going to get to Utopia we're
never going to get to the perfect
situation but we want it to be as close
to that as possible but if you're
constantly despairing that oh it's never
changing it's never getting any worse in
the face of or it's never getting any
better in in the face of evidence to the
contrary when you look at the Historical
picture then
the despair is going to prevent the that
momentum from uh continuing
um and it and it's not only that it's
also the flip side of that I'm just
pulling up a couple stats with regards
to Crime because we've heard a lot about
the recent crime spikes which are real
when you talk about murders in U.S
cities of violent crime overall in U.S
cities post-pandemic there's been a
spike uh and that's something that is
you know driving a lot of the creation
of things like the Scorpion unit here
this is in the city of Memphis you see
the long-term Trend in major violent
crime up that that uptick post 2019
however
you still have to look at the big
picture on that as well this is the
federal the FBI crime data data Explorer
showing on the left there rate of
violent crime offenses by population
rate of homicide offenses by population
you see the that disturbing Spike there
at the end in the homicide but we still
need to acknowledge that uh there's a we
never want to get back up to that Hill
back in the 80s and 90s and we need to
stop that stop it from getting there but
we we need to be cognizant of of the big
picture so that
um we're not either underreacting or
overreacting yeah and you know a kind of
the playoff of that but you know from a
different angle too it's also
probably a mistake always to look at
police uh you know homicides or or
killings by the police uh you know and
if there's 1100 a year roughly you know
let's say that you know 90 of those are
totally justified you know that that's
flat that's important because it's the
most extreme thing but even in the crime
data you were showing yeah you know
looking at homicides homicides are
statistically rare compared to regular
crime or violent crime uh and I was
gonna say you know in New York City
after stop and frisk which was not
originally part of comps that it came in
later and um stop and frisk ended up
there you know there were hundreds of
thousands of people on the streets
almost exclusively young men mostly
black mostly uh Latino uh being stopped
by cops uh some leading to arrests and
things like that and it's like the the
the way policing is done it can be
incred incredibly disruptive to
everybody's life I mean I think what
Walter Capps was talking about at one
point is the case a traffic stop may
look benign compared to being pulled out
of your car and beaten to death by the
police but as you were talking about in
your personal experience it is deeply
traumatizing it is also true you know up
until recently there were a million
years in a typical year there were a
million arrests for marijuana possession
across the country and you know nothing
happened to virtually all of those
people but being arrested you know is
not a small thing and it can be
disruptive enough to either cause you
know mental issues in people where the
you know their lives are disrupted or
their their lives are actually disrupted
and they lose their job or you know
relationships go downhill like we need
to be thinking about this stuff how do
we have as light a footprint as possible
uh using the you know the the state and
the Monopoly on violence that the state
has
to maintain the peace and you know the
other thing to stop blathering on about
this like I'm old enough to remember a
period you know in the 70s and the 80s
and then at beginning of of rising crime
in general particularly violent crime I
mean for a 30-year period crime was a
national issue in political races it it
has only recently become that again and
you know it's not exactly clear why
crime violent crime started declining in
the 90s the way that it did virtually
all criminologists at the time
regardless of ideology or political uh
you know commitment we're expecting it
to keep going up and up and up everybody
bought into you know the rise of the
super Predator uh kind of theory that
was just a given and it started
declining you know part of the decline
was policing part of it is a large
number of demographic factors economic
factors cultural factors you know
environmental factors that people
disagree on there's not a clear thing so
we need to keep crime down but we also
need to recognize that policing also you
know can help do that obviously but also
it can't be given you know a kind of
carte blanche to start disrupting
everybody's lives regardless of you know
civil liberties yeah absolutely you know
what what I took from that experience
and again this was just one incident
that happened to me uh I was leaving a
parking lot that where there was some
sort of you know undercover drug bust
happening and a guy you know pointed to
me as I was leaving and I guess the cops
thought I was his associate and they
ended up pulling me over taking me out
of the car cupping me and uh at the end
of the day you know they didn't rough me
up or anything but even just that
encounter I was like man I hate cops now
and I was like every time I would see a
cop for you know months after that I
would get a little like you know worked
up from and so imagine that you are in a
demo in a demographic and and maybe
people have experienced this just from
being pulled over on the highway and
having a rude interaction with a cop but
imagine that you are in a demographic in
a neighborhood where the police are just
aggressively you know checking in on
people to try to you know keep things on
you know for public safety reasons but
there's often going to be people who
they're not doing anything wrong and
every time that interaction happens it's
just going to get heightened and
heightened and there's more chance that
the person is going to yeah have an
attitude with the officer and so that's
why more that the cop is having a bad
day and they've got the attitude I mean
it's yeah you know one of the most
interesting studies uh in the wake of
the George Floyd killing uh that was I
know we discussed that reason in various
articles and videos and whatnot was that
in any given police encounter her the
odds of you of it escalating to an
arrest or any kind of violent
interaction is is you know
excruciatingly small but it was true
that you know and this is a place where
race plays into things where blacks and
Latinos are more likely to have more
interactions and so even if it's a you
know half of a percent chance if you
quintuple the number of encounters with
the police you're increasing the odds of
a bad outcome
um you know and that's the type of thing
to uh you know to keep in mind
um so uh Zach I think we have uh talked
a uh through just about everything is
there anything that you are
um you know that you want to end on
well uh you know just to that last point
I that this this is why I think that you
know for uh Libertarians especially but
really anyone who cares about police
reform figuring out ways to minimize
unnecessary interactions with the police
is really like the the key and and what
what I'm focused on and what what I hope
you know comes out of this and uh the
the work that you know Walter Katz is
doing with uh our Arnold Ventures I I
really appreciate you know first of all
how data driven it is they're they're
trying to look at small you know run
small pilot programs and actually
document results and say what can we do
to reduce those interactions while also
acknowledging you know police play an
important role in keeping Public Safety
that we don't want to compromise like
there I this is one of the things that I
think there's just pretty broad societal
like consensus on that we want those two
things less police brutality more Public
Safety and the only way to get there is
really to look at the policies and what
affects their their having and so that's
why I I really appreciate uh Walter
taking the time to come on talk through
some of it with us and I I encourage you
to check out the work that um uh Arnold
Ventress has done on police reform and
all that yeah all that all everything
that we referenced here and in in every
stream will be in the show notes below
so please you know dig into that if
you're interested yeah and uh just to
add on that go to the show notes follow
Walter Katz on Twitter uh it's he's an
extremely uh excellent follow uh and
Arnold Ventures which I should uh add
funds reason Foundation the non-profit
that published publishes reason it's a
uh really fantastic organization that's
simply because it funds us but it is
doing stuff on everything from pension
reform to police reform and things like
that they are a data driven really sharp
and good organization
um I'll also just end it by saying you
know we appreciate people watching the
live streams please send Zach and me and
we have open DMS on Twitter he's at The
Abridged Zach z-a-c-k I'm at Nick
Gillespie on Twitter
z-a-c-h excuse me I'm sorry my uh my uh
memory is going here it's uh but um you
know send us ideas or put them in the
the reason Twitter feed send them to uh
you know the uh uh you know add reason
emails uh who do you want to see on live
streams what topics do you want to see
covered and things like that Zach is
going to go missing next week on the
live stream because he is going to be
shooting on location uh in the great
state of Texas
uh but we'll be back next week at
Thursday at 1pm so uh on behalf of uh
Zach weismueller and uh Walter Katz
thanks for showing uh up at uh the
reason live stream thanks